[Music]
I've interviewed your husband Charlie
day yes quite a bit and lovely guy I'm
just curious how you two met we met a
really very long time ago
no you didn't meet on the show right we
didn't know I was I was 22 years old I
just graduated from college I was in New
York I was doing a play that was a wrap
the whole play was a wrap and I I met
Charlie he was doing a play we all went
out to a bar afterward and he he and his
friend both thought I was cute so they
arm wrestled to see who could talk to me
oh you know that's not wait they both
wanted to talk to you yeah but they
decided only one of us can really
approach yeah so we will arm wrestle did
you notice that they were arm wrestling
fear actually I didn't
it's usually the first thing I do when I
walk into a bar is like see where's the
arm wrestling happening you know but I
didn't notice that he that night so yeah
there was like a very very drunk Irish
man talking very close to my face
I was not bad yeah Wow
so sad all right so he actually he won
which is he rescued me from a drunken
Irishman and history and you have a
child you have a we have a four year old
boy four year old boy do you think he's
gonna be an actor I mean you're both
actors you have a child I don't know
he's so dramatic
I mean four-year-olds are just dramatic
but ours is he's a I think he might be a
director he likes to tell us what to do
a lot and it kind of works out because
we're both actors so he's like I fell
down and I'm crying now you fall down
and you cry and we're like oh okay
yeah dude should I fall here here you
know and he's like quite hard oh and I'm
like okay yeah I can I may cry tears
yeah and he's like widen out cut - yeah
he could be he could very well be he
does he doesn't get my best takes
usually no patience there's not the
patience
you